hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast best practices for CF DNA and
ffpe sample prep to ensure successful
downstream outcomes I am Brenda Kelly
chem lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event lab routes
comm is the leading scientific social
networking site and we are proud to
bring you this interactive web seminar
for more information please visit us at
wwwbootysha this webinar is sponsored by
PerkinElmer perkin element is a global
leader focused on improving the health
and safety of people and the environment
our dedicated team of 7700 employees
worldwide are passionate about providing
customers with an unmatched experience
as they help solve critical issues in
human and environmental health our
innovative market knowledge and
expertise help customers gain greater
insights into their science to better
protect our environment our food supply
and the health of our families for more
information please visit www com here's
how today's presentation works we want
to hear from you questions comments and
even some answers can be submitted via
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of your screen will try to get to
everyone but if not we'll make sure and
follow up with you by e-mail you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
please let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or the
QA button in the lower left I'd now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Alex
Lopez dr. Alex Lopez received his PhD in
biology from Cleveland State University
in 2002 with a concentration in
molecular parasitology and he collected
his MBA from cleveland state university
in 2004 he received his Bachelor of
Science near ohio state university in
1995 you joined chem engine in 2010 and
subsequently perkin-elmer in 2011
following the acquisition of pemmican
technologies
prior to that worked as a research
associate to the usda-ars at Cornell
University and had a postdoctoral
fellowship Case Western Reserve
University I'll now turn it over to dr.
Lopez for his presentation thank you
very much Brenda hello everyone and good
morning I'd like to present my talk on
the best practice for circulating
cell-free DNA sample prep ensuring
successful downstream outcomes in this
talk I want to go over the main points
of what I want to discuss so what I'd
like to do is just give a brief
introduction to CF DNA as well as
following with workflow solutions of C
of DNA specifically focus on
pre-processing and then the heart of
this is the circulating cell-free DNA
extraction solution presented by the
chemin automation technology afterward
discuss post extraction analyses as well
as a special research collaboration
effort between PerkinElmer and Swift
Biosciences in a post that we presented
at a brf recently and this shows an
example of a complete workflow and then
finally I'd also like to talk about
additional research applications for DNA
extraction with formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded samples the reason the
tie-in between circulating cell-free DNA
as well as paraffin-embedded tissue is
that both are very difficult to isolate
nucleic acids quality is lower in terms
of as well as yield so that there are
certain challenges to isolating this so
I will start by presenting with the
circulating cell-free DNA background so
what is the FDA so it's basically DNA
that's circulating in the bloodstream it
basically can originate from the
breakdown of cells you know whether it's
you know white blood cells and and so on
also you get some from breakdown of
pathogen as well as epic ptosis and
necrosis and
typically they're a tool for the
research of non-invasive prenatal
testing as well as transplant controlled
sports medicine pathogen detection in
terms of an indirect effect of what
pathogens due to the fragmenting of you
know DNA in terms of being in this size
area with circulating as well as a
camera cancer research in terms of what
a lot of people call us circulating
tumor DNA or CT DNA also this is also
commonly referred to as liquid biopsies
in terms of being able to take the
plasma isolate these small fragments of
circulating cell-free DNA and being able
to analyze and use this for any sort of
research testing so some facts about
circuiting cell-free DNA essentially
it's a needle in a haystack or even more
so as my colleague like say it's more of
a piece of hay in a haystack because
you're essentially isolating a very
small piece of DNA out of a sea of other
DNA and the challenge is to really get a
good clean prep not only just isolate
yield but also to get a certain purity
that will allow you to do use this
effectively and study effectively number
of downstream analysis such as next-gen
sequencing and so on so essentially it's
very it represents a very small portion
of the plasma so basically 115 anagrams
of circulating cell-free DNA in per mil
of plasma it includes all somatic and
field DNA as well as wild-type and
mutant and the Tartar fraction is only
one thirty percent and in terms of
mutation frequency especially with
interest to CT DNA it's only about one
to two percent so you really first of
all getting a very small portion of
circuiting cell-free DNA out and then
out of then if you're going to do any
sort of mutation frequency it's even
smaller so to ensure reliable results
you really need to use as much class as
possible but I'll also talk about some
of the benefits and drawbacks of you
know using different amounts of plasma
and how this would work so essentially
this is a trace that shows if you look
at the trace from left to right you have
your lower molecular law lower molecular
weight marker on the left and on the
extreme right have a higher molecular
weight
curr typically a circulating cell-free
DNA comes at a fraction but 160 668 168
base pairs which represents the
wraparound of DNA around a nucleus own
plus spacer you also have these other
fractions 368 and 552 we're presenting
two or three turns around the nucleus
ohm also you see a little bit at the
right near the high molecular weight
markers a little bit of genomic DNA
which in is basically the challenge of
doing this in that you know the idea is
you really want to have a good
signal-to-noise ratio that will allow
you to do with the downstream study it's
not enough just to purify it but to
really get a clean preparation from that
so let's talk about the workflow and
really what were what I want to focus on
this in this talk so first we talked
about blood collection and there are
some aspects to how blood is collected
and then we talked about plasma
separation and then really what we're
showing and really highlighting is the
circulating so for DNA extraction using
our / Cadel mark imogen magnetic bead
technology to go more in detail and then
finally downstream analyses and results
so at first you have the challenge of
which tubes do you want to use for the
collection and typically you have either
regular blood tubes which are standard
lavender top EDTA citrate tubes so both
and then you have this in comparison
with specialized circulating cell-free
DNA blood tubes such as an example
struck BCT cell-free DNA tubes both have
benefits and drawbacks the with the
regular blood tubes they typically don't
stabilize the white blood cells meaning
that if you're going to do any sort of
circulating self renounced you have to
produce the planet very quickly you know
within four hours of collection and thus
they're not really not really suited for
transport one of the benefits is that
they are definitely cheaper and
certainly there's you know because these
tubes are very popular and used for a
lot of you know whole blood extraction
genomic DNA that they're well known to
be compatible with a number of molecular
tests
the specialized circulating cell-free
DNA tubes basically you get a minimal
background of genomic DNA so you men you
basically stabilize white blood cells
and you also it also minimizes the DNA
background genomic DNA background it's
basically possible to ship them they're
glass tubes they definitely cost more
but the other benefit is that they're
well students for storage at three or
five days at room temperature it's
definitely possible so you know let me
let me go back to this flashlight one of
the you know I guess drawbacks of using
specialized cfd ni tubes I think one of
the primary ones have to do with cost as
well as procurement at different blood
collection centers one of the things
though in terms of thinking about doing
liquid biopsies is that the you know
there's certain you know drawbacks to
using the regular blood tubes because
even though they're cheaper you may also
have a higher opportunity cost because
you have to deal with having a fast
collection plasma separation transport
and being able to process them in a
pretty short amount of time so even
though the tubes themselves are cheap
you can also have a lot of drawbacks and
that you might have to do recollects
especially if the quality of the DNA is
not good either because it degrades or
because what we see is a high genomic
background which I'll highlight in this
next slide if you look at the two
comparative traces the one on the left
our regular blood tube so you could see
the at the left end the low molecular
weight marker on let me just point this
out so right here you have your low
molecular weight marker right here
whereas the peak of interest that we're
looking at for circuiting is right here
about 168 base pairs what we see at the
right end though is we see a lot of
noise in the genomic DNA region so
essentially we have with these EDTA
tubes essentially more genomic DNA
background compared to the signal that
we're trying to isolate whereas when
we're using specialized tubes again such
as the strike VCT tubes you could see
the 168 base pair peak represented on at
by the arrow here and you could see a
much lower genomic DNA background and
then you have your high molecular weight
peak here so again you know part of it
is you know availability of tubes being
able to use them but there is definitely
a benefit to using the specialized blood
tubes in order to get the highest
quality results so that's one aspect
another aspect is how does plans when
separated and what we've seen from
different customers is different methods
that were used essentially people have
used you know 10 ml starting blood line
which can be common for again either
stabilize blood tubes you know with a
stabilizing solution as well as EDTA
tubes and again you have to press some
less than four in four hours after blood
draw and you have to you know so
basically you have some mild sentra
fication conditions in order to separate
the plasma so these are just examples of
three customers using different sentence
steps in order to collect one of the
challenges as well as you have the crime
precipitate on that you may say
especially in some non stabilize blood
tubes which could cause some lipid
lipids to be found in the resulting data
DNA element because this could present a
challenge as well as other proteins so
what we say will mean by less is more
because even though earlier is saying
that you know we want to use as much
plasma as possible the goal is to really
make sure that you get a clean isolation
of the plasma from the separation so the
plasma on essentially contains for 25
MLS of or the I'm sorry the blood draw
contains four or five ml's of plasma
about fifty five percent of the total
blood and then you have the buffy coat
layer which contains the leukocytes and
platelets as well as the one percent of
total blood and then below you have the
erythrocyte layer so the idea is that
one has to be careful to isolate plasma
that does not disrupt or interfere with
the especially the buffy coat layer so
that we don't get unwanted Lucas
sites which then can contribute more
genomic DNA to the background this can
also be achieved so just some facts
about what you find in the different
fractions so essentially with plasma you
have water proteins electrolytes
circulating cell free DNA which contains
all the various forms of circuiting cell
free DNA on 60 200 million leukocytes or
milligrams of DNA found in the buffy
coat and then you also have a lot of
mRNA fun in the 50 billion erythrocytes
so as a thing with the buffy coat you
really don't want to disturb this so
there are methods to either be very
careful about removing the plasma either
through serological I petting or there's
also automated measures using either
lasers or cameras in order to isolate
the plans without disrupting the layer
using you know specialized liquid
handling platforms so what you know
again is a established earlier there are
definitely challenges to isolating
circulating cell free DNA from the from
the sample so essentially again you're
going to have in many cases more than
four males of plasma you're gonna have a
low amount of genomic turn up sorry
targets circulating cell free DNA you're
gonna have small fragments and then you
also have to deal with CF DNA protein
complexes as we noted that there are DNA
is linked with the nucleus um so
essentially you have these complexes but
they have to be broken so in addition
and plans me you also find a lot of high
protein content as well such as you know
immunoglobin that you find in these so
essentially you need to really get the
highest recovery and also get a purity
that really works with a number of
sensitive downstream research
applications
so what I want to discuss is how do we
fit in in terms of the command check
solution I'm using our pendant on
magnetic particles for doing this
isolation and how can we essentially
provide a solution that really gives you
a nice pure product as well as getting a
nice yield down for a number of
downstream applications so basically
with our technology it's a magnetic
need-based I'll go into the structure of
the magnetic beads themselves but
essentially what makes us different are
our magnetic beads themselves as well as
the method of how we use the automation
technology by using a combination of
magnetic separation through an
electromagnet and also the ability of a
stirring motor to turn the rods so that
you can get an efficient mixing of
particles in the magnets off so if you
look you have the electric coil which
basically the electric coil power is on
so you have the magnetism and then when
that happens you could look in looking
on the picture on the right let me just
point this out you have won the power is
on you can see you know first of all the
magnets off and the rod rod motor is on
and it's mixing and then the same time
you have the magnet beat collecting at
the bottom of the magnetic rod covered
by a disposable sleeve so when the metal
rod is connected to a stirring motor
when the steering motor is turned on and
magnetic fields and do some powers
turned off the rods could spin around
3,000 rpm enabling a smooth and very
efficient resuspension of the attractive
magnetic particles okay so we can see
that the one of the big benefits of our
automation technologies we have a very
flexible format system that can work
with both low lime and high volume so
the most appropriate erstand form is the
SBS format and this could work in 96 48
or 24 well plates so one of the most
common workflow that I'll talk about
especially in our example with Swift is
our 24 redhead solution that can use up
to four ml's of plasma
so if you look you could see the how the
commander Grodd head 24 works and how
the rods are arranged in a way that that
fits with the plates so let me just draw
this arrow here and then you can see how
the day rod arrangement then works with
with the plates there as well as we also
have a 96 round head that could work
with either 96 or 96 or 48 well plates
and both of these can be used as well
and i'll talk about the different
solutions we have a circulating
cell-free this also is the format that
we use for the fixed formal and
paraffin-embedded tissue that i'll talk
about the at the end of the talk and we
also have the ability for very large
samples up to 10 ml of plasma we can use
the 12 red head which essentially uses
reaction vessels that just consist of a
single 50 50 ml falcon conical tubes so
with our separation technology we
essentially have switchable magnets and
rotating rods it basically transfers
magnetic beads not liquid so unlike
system where you have a single tube in
which you have a fixed magnet at the
bottom and you have liquid being
pipetted in mixed and then you have to
have liquid pipe headed out here we're
actually moving the beads from plate to
plate or tube to tube depending on the
format of the kinetic system you have so
essentially we get a very efficient
suspension of magnetic beads resulting
in a high binding efficiency as well as
very efficient collection of magnetic
bead results in high recovery nucleic
acids efficient suspension of magnetic
beads results in a high washing
efficiency and technology allows the
processing of higher volumes one of our
strengths as well as we can show that we
get no cross combination between the
samples by very careful mixing that are
rotted stirring motor is able to do and
a number of methods within our isolation
system to ensure that we don't get any
cross-contamination so what are some of
the solutions that we have for
circulating cell-free DNA extraction so
one of the most common
that we've come up that we've seen with
with opportunities as well as talking
number of customers is this sort of
medium volume DNA extracts from four
miles of plasma now again everyone's
going to have different targets for the
amount of plans where they want to use
so a lot of times you know circulating
tumor DNA research can involve you know
as little as 1 ml of plasma up to four
ml's sometimes if one's looking at doing
you know fetal DNA analysis for research
that basically you can use higher
volumes for 2 10 ml so I'll talk about
really one of the more common workflows
we have as a formal plasma so
essentially we take four miles of plasma
that's been separated and isolated clean
and we try to make sure that it's clear
cryo precipitates based on the Santa
vacation conditions listed earlier we
add 1.6 ml's of lysis buffer as well as
proteinase K because is pointed out the
there is a degree of a lot of proteins
in the protein in the plasma samples as
well as the CF DNA protein complexes so
we really need to do a rigorous protein
age digestion so we do this at 60
degrees afterward the lights are put
onto the instrument and with the
addition of binding buffer in the
magnetic beads we have a pretty fast a
binding time for binding the DNA to the
beads and this is really essentially
going after very low molecular weight a
DNA which would correspond to the 168
base pair region so one thing I'd also
like to point out too is that we've seen
that you know with the circulating
cell-free DNA we see a range of about
168 basis but we also see that with some
circulating tumor DNA that we have lower
molecular weight as well that
corresponds 140 547 base pairs so the
idea is that our solution can really
isolate all circulating DNA for a number
of different purposes so after the
binding we have two repetitions of three
ml's of wash buffer three and two mils
or two repetitions of three ml wash
buffer for followed by a drying step
that we implement on the instrument as
well as the transfer to elution tubes
and you essentially loot in a very
triste lo EDT a buffer to stabilize the
circulating cell-free DNA in solution so
pointed out earlier the commander 360
which is our one of our featured
instruments for doing this isolation
will use 24 magnetizable of magnetic
rods and they're arranged to fit in the
SBS format 24 Depot play so just a
little bit of detail on our technology
magnetic beads so some of our benefits
so we are beads are different because of
several several things one we have a
high degree of magnetite which allow our
beads to very efficiently collect on our
on our rods when magnetized so that
results in a very fast magnetic
separation the hydrophilic need surface
with non measurable protein or
background for proteins results in very
pure nucleic acid isolation especially
in contrast to silica particles these
beads can be eluded at room temperature
and our specific bead surface with a
high of a high affinity uniquely guests
results in high quantitative yields as
well as high a degree of purity and it's
a very scalable process as I mentioned
with the different workflows so our
unique mpv a or polyvinyl alcohol coated
beats you can see on the left you can
see the size of our beads were partly
approximately 1 micron in diameter and
you can see the electromagnet Ron
microscopy picture of the dried mpv a
magnetic beads so the different kits
that we have you know the CMG 1104
refers to the formal plans mcklein that
we have that we could run on our
high-throughput systems either the
kinetic 360 Orca magic MSM one which are
shown below just just to illustrate this
is the kinetic 360 and this is the
command Jack MSM one so both instruments
use the same rod heads and essentially
they're just two different versions of
the instrument the MSM one being in the
field longer than 360 being the newer
instrument we also have
second kit listed the CMG 1090 dash a is
a kit that will that still uses the
forum l I'm sorry the 24 rot head but
instead uses two plates to bind
consecutive formal solution ice plasma
lights in order to do a complete 8 ml
isolation using this gives a higher
throughput and lastly we have the CMG
1110 which refers to the Comanche
circulating cell-free DNA 10 ml kit and
that's the one that uses our 12 rod head
and basically uses 50ml conical tubes so
in a sense once the plans are separated
and you can you use these tubes foot
perform the lysis it's a very rapid and
simple procedure for putting on the
instrument so as I mentioned these
results are very scalable so if you look
at an example trace you see again with
the low molecular weight marker hyper
marker you could see what we get from 10
ml's of plasma for mel's of input plasma
and 1 ml of plasma just to scale us take
a step back before I move on is we also
do have a solution for one amount plans
by using our 96 rod head that
essentially we can split the one mls
into 333 microliters and use three
plates in concert so basically it
results in a high-throughput 96 amps at
a time one ml isolation especially again
popular for a lot of CT DNA especially
if people are doing a lot of endpoint
targeted pcr such as epidermal growth
factor receptor tests so again this
gives you the idea of what we get in
terms of the scalability and essentially
we get a 2 2 to 5 nanograms of CF DNA
fraction or middle of plasma so one
thing I like to talk about and i will
definitely expand on this during the
discussion on the poster is that there
are a number of different you know i
think means to measure the quality and
quantity of the circulating cell-free
DNA
so some of the comments are is that with
circulating cell free DNA it's it's
definitely more challenging to quantify
without any sort of advanced analysis
because essentially what works well for
a number of genomic dnas such as genomic
DNA from either tissue blood saliva and
so on I'm using simple UV measurements
such as a nanodrop works works fairly
well in terms of giving a good you know
approximation of yield as well as purity
fluorimetric that that would analyze for
example double-stranded DNA or can also
specifically analyze on you know
single-stranded RNA is also very
effective for those sample types however
as I mentioned that we we're talking
about isolating a needle and haystack or
piece of hay in a haystack and
essentially what that means is that
we're trying to look at DNA amongst DNA
and the only way we can do that in terms
of really being able to quantify
circulating so free DNA is to use a
method that actually takes sighs into
consideration and these first two
methods really do not do that so in
order to really accurately quantify and
qualify and qualify the amount of
circulating cell free DNA in your
isolation you really need either the use
of a trace so fragment analysis
PerkinElmer has a lab chip GX touch that
is capable of doing this as well as
quantitative PCR digital droplet pcr and
then what is done sort of downstream of
that would be next-gen sequencing in
order to really give a good
qualification of what you know how good
the isolation is so essentially I'll be
talking about especially they cute one
method to isolate or analyzed using qpcr
and as you've seen with the earlier
traces having a trace is really helpful
and being able to actually depict the
amount of circulating cell-free DNA in
in the fraction and you can also look at
the genomic DNA contamination in that as
well so a number of downstream research
applications of leaves with our system
can be used for whole genome sequencing
amplicon sequencing snip targeted
sequencing instead qpcr arrays
snip arrays as well as backs on beads
essentially analyses so in these next
set of slides I want to talk about the
research poster collaboration that we
presented at a vrf recently and this
this involves a complete workflow
between not only the chem engine
technologies but PerkinElmer as a whole
and also a partner with us with
Biosciences in terms of showing this
research application that be very useful
so let's just shows the poster that we
had presented showing this workflow and
what I'd like to do in the next slides
are is to expand on a lot of these
figures and talk about you know in terms
of both able to the ability to quantify
as well as using our DNA for the next
gen sequencing analysis of this as well
as feature how Swift provides it means
to really generate libraries using very
low in you know such challenging samples
such as circulating cell-free DNA and
FFP paraffin-embedded formalin-fixed
issue so you know it's there are
definitely challenges and said earlier
you know again piece of hay in a
haystack we want to be able to show
sequencing more from less input so as
you can see when you have when you're
dealing with a circulating cell-free DNA
you're also you're dealing with a low
quantity as well as integrity so you can
see high molecular weight DNA and you
get a high degree of integrity it's a
little easier to isolate and then you
have if you're going from top to bottom
i'm going to show you the arrow right
here so you can see as you're going down
you have partially degraded DNA as well
as whole GM array you know
paraffin-embedded and then circuiting
cell-free so that is definitely the
challenge you're dealing with a lower
amount of integrity as well as if you
scale this with the quantity lower
amount of quantity so it is important to
have methods that could really generate
libraries especially post extraction
that can give you a good analysis of
what the consistent in the information
that one
that you want to get from that so I
mentioned different means of quantifying
in circulating cell free DNA one I would
like to spend a few minutes on is talk
about a specific method that was used to
calculate not only the yield of
cell-free DNA using a quantitative PCR
method but also to determine the quality
score that would be similarly
represented from a trace so what I'd
like to what this method is is basically
a method that uses that al repeats which
are essentially three hundred nucleotide
long very abundant sequences in the
genome counts constitutes about ten
percent of the genome and especially
abundant in blood and this method that
was developed by TB how at all in 20
2014 british journal of cancer article
popular manuscript that uses essentially
two sets of primers that amplify 115
base pair amplicon and the 247 base pair
amplicon i'm using these allergy gnomic
repeats so what they did was they
generated 115 basement amplicon that
represents the circulating cell-free DNA
whereas the 247 base for amplicon
represents a genomic DNA background so
by doing this you could look at the when
you look at the final concentration of
genomic DNA which is found in this
column here that is that is derived from
the 115 base pure amplicon so
essentially get the concentration than
unless you can calculate the yield the
quality score then is a ratio of the
amount of amplification from 247 / 115
amplicon so what they had done in their
research study was come up with these
different quality scores that with
regard to the ratio that that can do
that basically determine what they saw
in terms of what constituted a good
circulating cell-free DNA prep genomic
DNA as well as what they found with a
colorectal cancer patient so essentially
they found that with a mean of zero
three eight with a range of 0 point 0 to
9 or 0.29
is 0.49 they found that sir good quality
circuiting cell-free found was found in
this region they found from a colorectal
cancer patient about 0.62 in their
research study with a range of point 51
2.65 whereas genomic DNA you know an
example of contaminated genomic DNA
would have a score of 1 so as you can
see from this study that we did we did
had 10 samples that we isolated using
the commander 360 using the formal
protocol we essentially got scores in
the range of 0 point 3 2.5 which would
indicate a good quality of circulating
so free DNA as one thing just wanted to
mention also is that this information is
available as a technical note found on
the Swift bio by website so if you want
to get more details it outlines the
primers PCR conditions and method that
was used to determine this so this also
provides a nice way to not only quantify
but also qualify circulating cell-free
DNA so as a you know against said
there's a challenge for working with
difficult samples so now that we've been
able to quantify the circuiting so free
DNA this goes into what Swift has in
terms of their special library adapters
that are able to work with difficult
samples such as FF PS circuiting
cell-free DNA and so on you can also
have you know some critical factors
include DNA damage size selection as
well as the depth of sequencing how many
rounds of sequencing you want to get for
the genome so basically one nanogram of
genomic DNA is equivalent 267 copies
that diploid human genome 334
chromosomal copies of any low locus and
achieving 101 percent detection of a
header heterozygous mutation is
equivalent to three chromosomal copy so
again very challenging procedure for
doing this type of analysis so what
Swift has are the what they call the XL
ng ng s 2 s plus and essentially they
are
linkers that in method that allows for
the use of damaged DNA as well as again
challenging DNA circulating cell-free
ffpe so essentially we're doing a
dephosphorylation of both of three and
five prime termina of the DNA fragment
which helps reduce chimera formation and
improves ligation then they do a repair
of both of the three and five prime ends
eliminating damaged basis they then do a
sub sequential ligation of the p7 and p5
adapters and that also prevents adapter
dimer formation and eliminates the need
for adapter titration then there is an
optional pcr step but one of the key
things is that this can be done pcr free
with low amounts of input but is also
you can have the option of doing pcr so
you can see the different ranges of pcr
three inputs down to ten nanograms with
pcr inputs down to ten pika grams and
then you have the equivalent after
ligation efficiency at all input levels
so using our DNA extracted from the
Comanche 360 they're able to do with two
of these examples they were able to get
to knit with example1 example2 238
million and 254 million reads
respectively and you can see that they
have a had a good average genome
coverage of 14.6 times and 15.6 times
respectively and then you can see with
the mixed size distribution after you
know with with the circular DNA that you
get a nice meeting answered size of 169
basis essentially then libraries were
then sequenced on a high seek Agilent I
seek 2,500 and this just shows a
comparison of the genomic material to
the circulating cell-free DNA again the
idea of either having up using ten
nanogram 100 nanograms of pcr free
versus 10 nanograms of pcr you can get
very similar yields of the you know
circulating cell free products we need
to we'd like to get for sitting up
sequencing
so it really is you know this ends up
leading to is that we have with this
workflow able to show a detection of 1%
mutation in CF DNA using hybridization
enrichment technologies so again with
this DNA that was isolated from the four
miles of plasma on the kinetic 360 each
sample rip since individual unique
ethnic background and detect mutations
that only 1% of CF DNA was spiked in and
then with that you can see how how well
with the different chromosomes in the
different positions chromosomes two
chromosomes 12 you could see the
effectiveness of the being able to
detect this spike in sample one percent
you know a into ten anagrams of B and
one percent a in the 10 milligrams of C
so really shows that with this with this
example research example that show a
good recovery of the allele frequency
being able to simulate what you can what
can be done in in terms of the
capabilities of this platform so you
have ever used you know these libraries
are made using three samples and using
the 2's Excel NGOs to its library kit as
well as the IDT Jen pan-cancer panel as
well and then they were sequence on the
Angelyn IC 2500 so with that then that
concludes a portion of that wanted to
talk about in terms of cell-free DNA I
wouldn't like to expand on some
additional research applications so
again since we talked about difficult to
isolate samples paraffin-embedded tissue
and again you're dealing with lower
quantity as well as lower quality wanted
to show some of this extraction
solutions that we have for these sample
types so essentially paraffin-embedded
tissue is as you know estimated that
there's 1,000,000,000 of these samples
worldwide and they're a common method
for research and solid tissue samples
they're an excellent resource for
genomic insights they have a high
throughput demand screening and we have
also have a research collaboration with
the kavars to attract system which all
so talk about as well as a pki workflow
so with the you know research product
updates we have a couple of examples I
wanted to give so with we have our high
throughput system using the Comanche MSM
one or 360 and essentially our kit
number 1099 shows the isolated automated
isolation of DNA from 15 to 15 micron
section using an equivalent of FFP
tissue with the technology using the 96
rod head so as I pointed out the 96
rotted is what we use for the isolation
of be remitted tissue the we also have a
smaller instrument that's capable of
isolating similar volume samples to our
96 round head kaltaka magic core pedo
which gives you 12 samples at a time so
let's just gives an example of how we do
so compared with competitor a and B in
the blue our solution and green shows
that we get a higher yield of total
nanograms of samples in various
different tissues including you know
breast colon liver and lung tissues so
you can see with these different tissue
blocks we have shown to have a very good
ice method of isolating you know genomic
DNA from the FFPE samples additionally
with these two isolation with these two
isolation kits again what we have also
shown in terms of not only a yield but
also with comparison a competitor we get
also we show in higher fragment sighs
when we do a head in comparison so we
could see with the different sample
sizes if you look on the left column
versus the right column these are our
isolations these are competitor
isolation so we can show a higher
fragment size with these various
different tissue samples with our
platform using the you know the command
Jack MSM 1 360 or the Comanche cupido we
also have a research collaboration with
co virus which uses a sonic
AFA acoustic focusing for removal of the
paraffin-embedded tissue and essentially
it was peered paired up with our
chemistry we have a we have a kit that
will work for the solution as well so
people have a solution that is using the
kavars system we have a specific it that
works for its again using either the MSM
one or 360 with it Church track DNA kit
or with the small entrance torpedo so
again with a with a chief competitor and
green versus blue we show that we have
higher yield of DNA from prostate colon
and lung with cim in comparison with it
primary competitor as in addition you
know again showing average fragment size
with either of our formats we show that
we have a very good average fragment
size form prostate colon and long as
well the thing we see is a little bit of
smaller size with with this with the
acoustic focusing but it also depends on
what you're going to be doing downstream
with this with this DNA so again we're
we just want to show that we're very
adaptable we have you know with regard
to perfect embedded tissue we could work
with a number of different means of
removing the paraffin whether it's done
through detergent xylene for example
using the kavars system that we have a
solution for all these different types
of deep paraffin ization so let's
summarize um so circuiting cell-free DNA
is typically observed as 100 products
168 base pair peak again the 168 base
pair peak involves the wrapper in the
nucleus own plus some linker DNA and
again we see a smaller slightly smaller
size for you know CT DNA specific
stabilize blood tubes for circulating
cell-free DNA such as the BCT strike VCT
tubes allow for greater stability of see
is CF DNA but also have less genomic DNA
contamination the our automated system
basically shows that we can have a very
flexible workflow
from one of ten ml's of plasma so
different formats for different needs
depending on what you're doing
downstream we have the solution that
would be you know offer the most economy
of scale in order to give you the best
either the highest throughput for what
you need and also we can do a very
higher amount of plasma in case you need
to isolate a greater amount of
circulating cell-free DNA qualitative
analyses such as fragmin announced QVC
our show specific yield to the targeted
size of the circulating cell-free DNA
and also represent and show the genomic
DNA contamination and through our
research effort collaboration revolution
entire workflow for the analysis of CF
DNA from for mel's of plasma and then as
an additional research application of
interest we have a solution that work
with a number of paraffin-embedded
tissues working with the cabarrus to
attract workstation as well as samples
he may have by using traditional means
of isolating or D paraffin izing samples
before we get to questions is want to
just give a couple reminders if you
would like to learn more of our
technology please visit our booth we
have a number of reps that are in booths
to answer your questions we also have a
video showing the kinetic 360
workstation and actions you can see in
more Illustrated detail how the
isolation works and i'll also be
available myself in the next hour i'm
from 1130-2 1230 eastern time to answer
an additional questions if they don't
get addressed in this question and
answer section and with that I thank you
very much for your time in participation
in this tutorial thank you dr. Lopez
excellent presentation lots of good
information before we get to questions
from our audience members i just want to
remind them how to reach us today
questions can be submitted by the green
Q&A button at the lower left of your
screen and we do have one right now in
our queue an attendee asks does the type
of heparin tubes for blood storage prior
to plasma isolation
impact the yield of cell-free DNA thank
you for the question so with regard to
heparin I mean this kind of gives this
falls under you know not only circuiting
cell-free DNA of a genomic DNA heparin
key lates with dnase notes being a
anticoagulant so it won't affect the
yield of the DNA isolation but it would
affect the ability especially of doing
any sort of pcr analysis unless you use
a specific it to remove the heparin from
the DNA the isolation process or any
extraction process would not remove the
heparin from that so no it wouldn't
affect the yield but yes it would it
would affect the you know quality of
downstream application depending on what
you want to do great thank you I do I
again want to let our audience know that
dr. Lopez will be taking your questions
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen type your
question into the box that appears and
dr. Lopez would be happy to answer your
questions here today dr. Lopez while we
wait for any questions to come in do you
have any other sort of summary comments
or advice for our audience members
audience members Thank You Brenda um yes
so if you have any specific questions in
terms of your workflow solutions what
you know you can see in terms of either
you know seeing what our system can do
for you and also even advice of
isolating or analyzing circulating DNA
please feel free to reach out and ask us
any questions said we've worked with a
number of opportunities and we realize
especially in the circuiting cell-free
DNA area a lot of methods are very you
know proprietary there's a lot of
there's there is some degree of
customization
with regard to that but I think what
we're trying to present is a workflow
solution that really shows a nice work
flow from all the way from sample
collection to analysis that we can work
with you and showing is an example of
how our technology plugs into a complete
workflow is something that really shows
how effective our extraction technology
is and well you know essentially what we
can really help you with in terms of
furthering your ability as a you know
organization to better analyze
circuiting cell-free DNA great thank you
for the information we do have another
question coming in um will the PDF copy
of this presentation be available all
right thank you basically yeah
essentially we can we can provide
something to you it just maybe collect
some information or just at least you
know talk with our you know regulatory
to make sure everything looks fine but i
think you know we definitely able to
provide that information for you great
thanks that'd be a great resource i'm
sure i don't see any more questions in
our queue so i'm going to once again
thank dr. Alex Lopez for being here
today bringing us this information I'd
also like to thank our sponsor
PerkinElmer and we'll leave it to dr.
Lopez to wrap up for us thank you thank
you very much again for giving me the
opportunity to present this technology
one thing to if you have again time to
visit us in the booth or talk you know
we'd like to just just from our
information as well like to find out
some aspects of what types of analysis
you're doing in terms of your CF DNA
where
flow an example how are you analyzing
the extraction yield quality as well as
a type of blood tubes and also volumes
so that you know so that in addition to
learning about what you're doing there
is the ability to you know again really
let's see if we can gear a solution that
we have with our flexible system to work
well for your platform or free or at
least if you're not doing currently
looking to do in the near future great
and I did misspeak we do actually have a
question an attendee asks do you find
there is any difference when you test CT
DNA and different cancer types yeah
thank you for the question so right now
is we're kind of focusing on this from a
research application I think to last
visit question we have not explored that
at this time I think in terms of working
with you know research collaboration
partners that would certainly be of
interest that it currently we have not
you know don't have any other other data
other than saying that that we do see in
this has been published in the
literature that the circulating tumor
DNA does show a smaller size than the
let's say circulating cell-free DNA from
quote unquote normal patients great
thank you lots of good information here
I do want to thank our sponsor
perkinelmer from making this webcast
possible and again dr. Lopez for
bringing the information to us and
taking time with us today and another
question dr. Lopez from start to finish
for the workflow how long does the
instrument take to analyze the specimens
how long do you estimate it takes to
prepare specimens for the kemah gen for
CF DNA different times for ffpe
ffpe so I think from from the question
so lemon let me what i can do is i can
kind of cycle back to the question about
or showing the workflow go back a little
bit so with the regard law will start
with ffpe with FFP essentially what
you're with the biggest challenge is to
basically d paraffin eyes the sample a
lot of times and it depends on if
somebody has already an established
workflow with a manual procedure there's
a number of ways to you know go after
again with the kavars to extract system
it's a very rapid using acoustic
adaptive focusing to break and remove
the paraffin from that it's it's it's
fairly rapid however there's also if
one's going to use any sort of like a
detergent or xylene I you know
extraction that takes I think what most
people do is especially with regard to
the proteinase k digestion they first
need to do the removal the paraffin and
then followed by proteinase k digestion
at 60 degrees and a lot of times people
are doing this overnight prior to
loading that lysate on the instrument
once that lysate is then generated the
runtime of the instruments approximately
45 50 minutes and that's that works for
one 296 samples i'm using the high
throughput system of msn or 360 as well
and then the low throughput system the
convention cupido 12 12 samples with the
circulating DNA then you know in terms
of the up front steps then all depends
on you know in terms of your blood
collection when you separate the plasma
and generating that plasma essentially
if we start with four male plasma we're
going to incubate about usually most
cases 60 minutes at 60 degrees with
doing a you know proper proteinase k
digestion with the lysis buffer and then
the binding is 40 minutes and then the
drawing five minutes so essentially
you're talking about two hours for the
extraction of circuiting cell-free DNA
from that point and then with the 360
will do is produce the circuiting
cell-free DNA and then in terms of
downstream analysis
that's up to you as far as how one wants
to quantify either using a you know
instrument that does trace analysis
looking at size fractionation or using a
you know either quantitative PCR digital
droplet pcr for that analysis depending
on how long the thermal cycling takes
for that thanks again so much I also do
want to thank our sponsor perkin-elmer
make today's webcast possible this
webcast is going to be available on
demand through November of 2016 and
you'll be receiving an email from lab
roots alerting you when this display is
when this presentation is available for
on-demand replay we would invite you to
forward that email to your colleagues
may have missed today's presentation
that's all we have for you today in this
presentation thank you again to dr.
Lopez perkinelmer for bringing this
information to you we hope we see you
again